[Musique]
bonjour vous regardez vous continuer à
regarder les images des chaînes de
télévision russes et on en apprend
beaucoup notamment sur les intentions de
poutine en ukraine oui aujourd'hui tout
le monde se demande mais quelle est donc
la stratégie de vladimir poutine à
l'heure où les représentants de moscou
souffle le chaud et le froid dix ans
d'abord que les pourparlers avec la
partie ukrainienne en turquie avant-hier
était constructif et puis qu'il ne
fallait rien attendre de prometteur il
ya un mois en dix ans de correspondance
en russie effectivement j'ai appris à
écouter la propagande des chaînes de
télévision russes pour répondre à cette
fameuse question que l'on me pose tout
le temps mais que se passe-t-il dans la
tête de vladimir poutine qu'est ce qu'il
veut et la propagande elle permet en
partie d'y répondre pourquoi parce que
son rôle c'est de prendre les messages
du kremlin de les amplifier de préparer
en quelque sorte l'opinion publique
russe allait recevoir jusqu'à ce que à
force de matraquage l'opinion publique
les fasse sien alors hier soir il
fallait entendre ce que vladimir
soloviov devait amener les rues sa
pensée on a déjà parlé de lui dans cette
chronique soloviov est l'un des
propagandistes en chef il connaît
personnellement en v'là d'inières
poutine son émission de débat est la
plus regardée le soir juste après la
grande messe informationnel du 20h sur
la chaîne d'état rossiya 1 écoutez son
ouverture hier soir de son émission de
débat il est 20 heures 20 à paris 21h20
à moscou
[Musique]
pas besoin de ces pays chasse
najet chose que je me permettrai une
fois de plus de commencer en étant clair
et précis pour expliquer la situation
dans notre pays les buts sont définis
par un seul homme le commandant en chef
des armées et les bus défini par le
commandant en chef des armées pour ce
qui est du cours de l'opération
militaire spéciale ont été formulées de
façon on ne peut plus clair berne entre
7 et 4 et nazification des mails étaient
les hôtes seraient militarisation un
statut neutre l'indépendance et la
sécurité des républiques populaires de
dounia tu es de lougansk c'est pourquoi
certaines hésitations survenu hier
heureusement que le peuple a compris
qu'il ne fallait écouter que le
commandant en chef des armées vient ceux
qui sont habilités à commenter certains
thèmes j'ai les boules du canton open a
mûri ching yng votre commentaire
oui ça rigole pas et l'ena il va même
jusqu'à en gaule et ses invités un oui
alors regardez la tête des analystes ont
mis en place par le maître de cérémonie
soloviov parce que suite à la rencontre
en turquie certains s'étaient permis
d'émettre des maîtres diverses
hypothèses et diverses interprétations
suite aux déclarations contradictoires
de moscou or la propagande elle n'est
pas là pour analyser et les là pour
livrer un seul et unique message aux
russes celui du kremlin la russie ne
cédera à l'ukraine ni la crimée qu'elle
annexée ni le dombass qu'elle a occupée
en 2014 écoutez cet autre ouverture
d'une émission de grande écoute 60
minutes toujours sur la même chaîne
rossiya 1
[Musique]
je décerne notamment guam dans 60
minutes l'essentiel de l'actualité
édition spéciale dernier urgent moscou
ne vois pas de résultats et de percer
après les pourparlers entre la russie et
kiev en turquie notre position sur la
grille mais le dombass reste gravé dans
le marbre et elle ne changera pas dire
sven manier mais voilà donc qui est
clair si on comprend bien lna y a pas de
compromis possible sur la crimée sur le
dombass et donc la guerre va continuer
exactement et donc la propagande ne pèse
pas d'un cran son agressivité c'est là
un autre mauvais signal parce que on
peut aussi juger d'une issue de
pourparlers positive ou négative à
l'intensité des discours propagandiste
ils ajustent leur niveau d'agressivité
au besoin de mobilisation d'adhésion de
l'opinion publique autour des actions de
vladimir poutine est là la propagande de
guerre elle est plus que jamais
agressive elle martèle les mots de
russophobie nazisme génocide avec tout
un champ lexical religieux aussi qui
présente un ennemi sataniques et comme
le sociologue lev goudkov nous le disait
hier soir dans cette chronique comme il
faut toujours un pendant positif et un
pendant négatif pour que cette
propagande fonctionne sur les esprits en
parallèle et bien la télévision russe
elle montre aussi de véritables
blockbusters pour glorifier montrer la
puissance la précision le succès de
l'armée russe dans ses opérations pour
comme a dit libéré l'ukraine des nazis
regardez le ministère russe de la
défense lui travaille selon le principe
les chiens aboient la caravane passe la
démilitarisation de l'ukraine se
poursuit 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
richard bove qui va chez le bourg de
soyaux
ils ont cinq minutes pour se mettre en
marche le prince heures du complexe de
missiles iskander relève le filet de
camouflage du véhicule de combat le
conducteur allumé le moteur à turbine à
gaz et le lance missile se met en marche
vers sa position de combat
le pointeur de se lance missile a été
tué plus de dix lancements depuis le
début de l'opération spéciale les
missiles ont atteint leur cible ils ont
détruit des aérodromes militaires des
entrepôts de combustible et de munitions
des systèmes de défense antiaérienne et
l'art spiri
avec une telle puissance derrière le dos
on se sent sûr de soi et de sans
armement
ça semble incroyable mais c'est une mise
en scène oui évidemment mise en scène
totale mais il faut bien comprendre que
s'est présentée comme un reportage de
réalité aux téléspectateurs russes peu
importe que ce ne soit pas crédible une
seconde l'essentiel c'est qu'ils doivent
percevoir cette opération spéciale qui
n'est jamais appelé une guerre
d'ailleurs par la télévision russe
puisque la nouvelle loi l'interdît on le
rappelle il l'essentiel est qu'ils
voient une armée forte puissante qui ne
rate jamais ses cibles des cibles qui
sont toujours militaire n'est ce pas
parce qu'il s'agit de démilitariser les
nazis des nazifié ans n'est ce pas
jamais les russes ne voit les dégâts les
morts la désolation le malheur des
ukrainiens dans cette guerre
dévastatrice
voilà donc pour le message positif qui
consiste à dire que le mal c'est le bien
et donc à éveiller ce sentiment
d'adhésion d'avoir d'amour pour l'armée
russe chez la population alors pour
revenir au pendant négatif de la
propagande parce que puisque la guerre
se poursuit il ne faut pas perdre de vue
qu'ils sont nos ennemis et qui sont nos
alliés la propagande continue de peindre
l' axe du bien contre l' axe du mal avec
cette visite notamment du ministre russe
des affaires étrangères sergueï lavrov
en chine y regarder keita s 09 h les
pays bas voire les ministères des
affaires étrangères russe et chinois se
sont rencontrés en chine lavrov a
déclaré que moscou et pékin y est
ensemble vers un nouvel ordre mondial
plus juste et multipolaire et ça à
l'évidence cette rencontre et ses
déclarations énerve washington john ford
des stater paul pace why not au fait
figurez vous que cette nuit tout d'un
coup by john interdit le lynchage elle
est le lynchage c'est un assassinat de
groupe extra judiciaires alors que la
simulation de noyade elle reste
autorisée aux états unis et après ils
veulent pas prendre à nos civilisations
millénaires à se curer les faits patents
metelo des rich green et savez les
attaques aux valeurs sûres la
voilà donc dès qu'on parle de washington
hop rien à voir au fait joe biden
interdit le lynchage immédiatement
quitte à passer du coq à l'âne ans
raconte le pire de ce que l'on peut
trouver de pire à raconter sur le moment
sur les états unis et selon le principe
de ce qui n'est pas interdit est
autorisé la propagande russe prétend que
la simulation de noyade est autorisé aux
états unis références sont breuer un
espace de la prison américaine de
guantanamo ce qui est évidemment un
effet de loupe sur le passé mais la
propagande ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
qu'elle nous dit aujourd'hui les ennemis
sont là l'opération spéciale en ukraine
se poursuit ne perdons pas de vue nos
objectifs et la russie lé victorieuse
elle ne cédera pas merci beaucoup et
l'ena pour ce décryptage de fake news